Guys, you're never gonna believe this.
We are on an emergency mission because the Snap Bot
SnapChat Spectacles' Bot is now setup in Santa Monica.
Jenna texted me said "Guess what. It's at the Pier."
I hopped in my car. I am driving not very fast because you can't really drive very fast in Santa Monica.
Jenna is on her way. We are gonna get ourselves some Snapchat Spectacles
I already have a pair, but I love them so much that I'm getting them for the Pittsburgh Penguins
because they tweeted me the day that I got them and asked if I could get them an extra pair.
So, I'm doing this for the Pittsburgh Penguins and because Jenna doesn't have them and a bunch of my
friends don't have them yet and honestly they're so cool.
I was skeptical of the spectacles, but I am a skeptic no more after using them.
They're pretty awesome.
So, lets go to the pier. Hope the line isn't too long and see what we can see.
Oh my goodness, I made it down here so quickly.
As quick as my little wheels could spin and there is an absolutely massive line.
Jenna's on her way. I'm a little bit nervous because I don't know if I'm actually gonna be able to get these things,
but I did pack snacks and I know how to camp out on a quick turn of a dime and we're here.
(Gasp) There it is!
Crap! This line goes all the way down.
I'm not sure this is gonna be-
Oh my God.
Holy crap, there are so many people here.
-Hey Justine
-[iJ] Hi
-Hey
-[iJ] How are you?
-Good
-Hi iJustine
-[iJ] Hello, how are you?
-You’re so late.
-[iJ] Hi, OK I-
-Hey, we got the same mic.
-[iJ] Very nice, very nice
-[iJ] My sister texted me. I was like, I just woke up
-Too late already.
-[iJ] I know. Oh my goodness, this is insane.
What've you got here?
So, these are tattoos, temporary, that are tweets and this is, uh, from Justin Bieber
and it says, "Like I said. Love wins"
and I also got some DJ Khaled
But I saw that he had Justin Bieber ones in there,
I was like, is there any way I can have one of those.
- twittertats.com
-[iJ] That’s awesome
OK, this is amazing.
Imma put these on later
-[iJ] Thank you. Nice meeting you.
- Yea, yea awesome. Yea, nice meeting you too.
There he is, there he is! Hello honey, Hi!
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness, oh boy!
I spilt coffee all over myself and almost-
and almost got in a car accident.
My sweet dog, how are you?
I missed you, I missed you.
OK, we got some really really bad news.
They said that they're not gonna restock it
and they're all out, but there's so many people here.
Their office is in Venice. It's super close.
Like, they could just get some more and put them in the Bot
-[iJ] Really?
-Yea, 70 people
-[iJ] That’s it? Ugh
-It’s completely closed
I think I'm gonna wait a little bit longer.
What do we do? Do we just go get food and cry into our omelettes?
-[Jenna] I'm always into crying into omelettes
-[iJ] Matty want to go cry into an omelette?
That little tail is going so fast haha awww!
"A" for effort everybody
-Trying to help you guys out a little bit.
-[iJ] You just convinced me to get back in line.
-I’m sorry
-[iJ] Are we really doing this?
-I have to leave by like 11 or something, the latest.
-[iJ] OK, alright, let’s get back in line.
I hope that our line-mates will accept us back.
Just said two seconds ago that I wasn't gonna get back in line and here I am getting back in line.
I'm doing it for the Pittsburgh Penguins.
OK, we're officially leaving now. This is just really sad.
-For SnapChat fans it’s a sad day
-[iJ] Right?
-That's right
-[iJ] Ugh!
-It's terrible.
So many sad people. There was like this little kid in a shark costume
and he's like "It was my birthday. I came here."
He's like, "I've never been so upset!"
-Love your book cover, by the way.
-[iJ] Oh thank you so much!
-Steve Jobs would be proud.
-[iJ] Thank you!
-Hey
-[iJ] Bye!
-You done?
-[iJ] Yea
Ok, Bye. Goodluck, Goodluck everybody!
I've given up.
Well, trying to get the Snapchat Spectacles was quite a spectacle.
At least, like at Apple when they didn't have any iPhones, they let people know and said "It's fine, you can go."
They were telling other people to just go tell people in line.
But, like, we don't know if we should believe the people or not.
I had to leave because I've got to go
do some work and edit and I have a shoot later today, so I, unfortunately, couldn't stay.
That's it for this video. This was just a random little Snapchat adventure.
I'm so sorry to the Pittsburgh Penguins because I was doing this for you guys.
I really wanted them to get the Specs, but no Specs.
At least, I met a lot of really cool people.
That's one of the things that I will say, that when you're waiting in lines for something, no matter what it is
You're gonna meet a lot of likeminded people because everyone's essentially waiting for the same thing
and clearly you're waiting for something that means a lot to you, or you wouldn't be waiting.
I think I said bye, like, four times in this video.
Peace out
So, here we go. This is the official unboxing.
Basically the only way to get these is through a vending machine called a Snap Bot.
Yea, a Snap Bot.
So, these are supposed to- I really actually don't know what they're gonna do. So here we are.
Have you done an unboxing before?
No, I don't even know what to do.
I feel, like, I apologize. Please forgive me because this is my first un-